the journey to find gold Rogers
legendary treasure has been long and
winding we've crossed the grand line
taken to Kingdoms in the sky and even
gone Toe to Toe with the world
government and although Luffy and his
crew haven't quite made it to the Finish
Line each new adventure has taken him a
step closer to becoming the king of the
Pirates now it's time for you to set
sail with the straw hat crew and have
your very own adventure with them in one
piece Odyssey the upcoming jrpg from
Bandai Namco entertainment Inc here's
everything you need to know about the
game
let's start with the story which is
brand new for the game one day after
minding their own business sailing the
sea the straw hat crew is beset by a
huge storm and they find themselves
stranded on a mysterious island called
wafford separated amidst the chaos Luffy
leads the charge to get the gang back
together and along the way they run into
two brand new characters a Dio and Lim
while adeo decides to help out the crew
Lim unfortunately hates Pirates and
takes the crew's abilities away from
them storing their power in cubes that
are spread out around the island but
she's also able to access Memoria which
is a world made up from the crew's
memories this means that you get to
experience some classic one-piece arcs
as you play through the adventure to
regain your power and uncover the
secrets of Wofford expect to relive key
moments from Alabaster water 7
marineford and dress Rosa and all the
intense emotions that came with those
beloved arcs one piece Odyssey is
similar to traditional jrpgs but of
course there are some one-piece style
twists you can play as the members of
the straw hat crew with each one having
different abilities both in battle and
during exploration enemies will wander
around the world and crossing paths with
them begins a fight battles are
turn-based and it's up to you to choose
the right abilities to emerge Victorious
the rock paper scissors nature of the
battles means that some abilities will
be more effective than others so using
the right ones in the right
circumstances is key to quickly and
decisively securing a victory
twist is that the battlefield is split
up into different areas with enemies and
the crew randomly assigned to different
zones this means that as is often the
case in the Manga and Anime the crew is
split up and Grand battles take place on
multiple fronts you'll need to use each
member of the straw hat crew to their
fullest potential to take out the
enemies that surround them of course as
all one piece fans know you're nothing
without your friends so other crew
members can also help out in skirmishes
so long as you remember your positioning
the dramatic scene system randomizes
aspects of the encounters too so for
example a member of the crew could be
surrounded by enemies and unable to
attack unless you help them out and take
the pressure off them completing the
randomized sub-objectives that pop up
will net you more rewards at the end of
each battle
if you're wandering around the Overworld
and see some shinies you can freely swap
between crew members and use their
abilities to uncover every secret and
hidden trinket Luffy can of course use
his stretchy rubber body to slingshot
himself around and zip across the world
while Zorro can use his expert
swordsmanship to chop down barriers
one piece Odyssey is being developed by
ilka or I love computer art a Japanese
Studio that has worked on many Beloved
jrpgs the music for the game was made by
famed composer motoi sakuraba who has
previously worked on a number of games
in the tales of series as well as the
Dark Souls series the team worked
carefully to ensure that one piece
Odyssey remained loyal to the spirit of
one piece so the characters have the
exaggerated facial features and
expressions they're known for and the
design of the island of wafford was
inspired by various aspects of the
one-piece Universe the game even
features new designs from Hiro Oda the
creator of One Piece who designed new
monsters and creatures including the dry
penguin and Leviathan as well as the new
characters Lim and adeo one piece
Odyssey will launch on January 13 2023
on PlayStation 4 PlayStation 5 Xbox
series X and S and PC and there are a
number of additions available
first up is the standard edition for
59.99 which includes the game and a
pre-order bonus made up of a bunch of
useful items 10 energy apples 10 excite
apples three golden jellies and 100 000
Berry as well as the traveling outfit
set costume for Luffy Zorro Sanji usop
Nami Chopper and Robin this Edition is
available both physically and digitally
the deluxe edition includes the game and
the pre-order bonuses I just mentioned
as well as a few other goodies it also
includes the deluxe pack which includes
two Jewelry accessories and the sniper
King traveling outfit it also contains
the adventure expansion pack which
includes one Ultra useful accessory set
100 000 Berry and an upcoming piece of
story downloadable content the deluxe
edition is 84.99 and is only available
digitally the collector's edition bundle
is available for PS4 PS5 and Xbox it
includes everything from the games
deluxe edition but also comes with a
figurine of Luffy and Lim this Edition
is exclusive to the Bandai Namco store
and will cost you
129.99 so there you have it everything
you need to know about One Piece Odyssey
for more on the game make sure to
subscribe to Gamespot on YouTube and
check out gamespot.com
[Music]